make no mistake outgunned outmann the
ukrainian military and the ukrainian
people they are heroically now fighting
for their country and for their very
existence their lives now they're using
outdated soviet-era fighters ukrainian
pilots guess what they're gunning down
modern russian planes on the ground
ukrainian soldiers they're taking out
dozens of russian tanks with
american-made javelin rockets and
meanwhile regular citizens men and women
all over the country of ukraine they're
picking up guns anything they can get
their hands on molotov cocktails they're
all preparing for urban war some kind of
insurgency and on a remote ukrainian
island in the black sea you had 13
ukrainian border guards they came under
attack from a russian warship instead of
surrendering they told the russians they
can go up themselves and they fought to
the bitter end listen to this courage
[Music]
every one of those people lost their
lives that night standing up for their
country in the face of certain death
they didn't back down and back at home
the president of the free world joe
biden he won't even stand up to the
climate change alarmists in his own
party and expand american oil and
american gas exploration drilling all
the things that we could do to ease the
pressure on our nato allies and our
western european partners and literally
remove the us from our dependence now
that he brought upon this country on
foreign energy including the millions of
barrels of oil that joe biden in 2021
imported from russia 232 million to be
exact now joe biden has created what is
a 40-year record high in inflation that
is hurting every single american that's
all because of his failed economic and
energy policies and these same policies
now artificially reduce the world's
supply of energy that's the lifeblood of
the world's economy it has weakened our
national security in ways too profound
to even calculate at this time and now
we're relying on let's see russia
opec saudi arabia for the lifeblood of
our economy by the way he inherited
energy independence he inherited america
as a net exporter of energy joe's
policies now have helped chase our
european friends and allies and nato
partners right into the arms of vladimir
putin we should be the ones supplying
them with their energy needs not russia
not vladimir putin who they're making
rich and by the way joe won't even stand
up to our allies in europe right now
he's being rolled by germany italy
belgium they don't want to remove russia
from the all-powerful swift banking
system because they're thinking about
their selfish economies well maybe their
country is going to be next maybe
they're on the list of countries to be
invaded and by the way russian oil could
be cut off and as a matter of fact
according to the biden administration
the sanctions are designed
specifically to keep russian oil flowing
now that would render every other
sanction
well meaningless it would negate every
other sanction if you're going to allow
russia to stay in the oil and and gas
and energy business that's where putin
is getting all the money to fund his
territorial ambitions take a look
what i'm saying is that our measures
were not designed to disrupt in any way
the current flow of energy from russia
to the world
now this is the single most important
sanction that joe should have put on
russia it's the only one that means
anything
joe is allowing putin to get even richer
as oil and gas is the lifeblood it is
fully half of russia's economy it
without the oil without the gas without
the sanctions on oil and gas guess what
you're not going to stop or deter
vladimir putin you're only aiding and
abetting him listen to this important
question for from our very own peter
ducey take a listen
what have you guys done
throughout this slow-moving russian
crisis that has worked
in what capacity well the president
talked to putin he talked to the g7 he
threatened sanctions he put sanctions in
place now he says the sanctions are
going to take 30 days
or about a month do you guys think the
people in ukraine have about a month
well peter let me just take a step back
and explain to everyone how diplomacy
works and how our approach from the
united states has worked uh what the
president has done is he has built a
global coalition uh to stand up in the
face of president putin
yes sanctions indeed but not the one
sanction that would be most meaningful
that would actually impact russia the
the most and be the most effective in
other words joe biden his administration
they're doing absolutely nothing which
is sadly for them par for the course you
might remember last may when biden did
nothing after russia hacked the colonial
pipeline system that caused massive gas
shortages all up and down the east coast
of america and in june when biden did
nothing after putin started surrounding
ukraine with tens of thousands of troops
of military equipment in july when biden
did nothing after putin delivered a
deranged message about restoring the
soviet union's former glory laying out
his plans for the future and on monday
when biden did nothing when putin told
the world that he was going to take
ukraine by force by the way i want to be
very clear
i'm not suggesting we have a shooting
war with russia i want to be very clear
on this but for crying out loud could we
at least
put the sanction that matters the most
in place and at least stop russia from
selling their oil and accumulating even
more money and more wealth that is
funding territorial ambitions like
ukraine could we maybe sanction russia's
energy production that is the one
sanction that would be meaningful at
least we could start producing more oil
and gas right here at home and then
america could get rich would be great
for national security wouldn't have to
worry about putin wouldn't have to worry
about the straits of hormuz or the
middle east we'd create high-paying
career jobs here in america and at the
same time we would be energy independent
and we'd be able to help out our nato
allies and western european countries
that desperately need
oil and energy for their economies
there's not a chance is there anyone in
the biden administration you know that's
not a total idiot at this point
now with keeve encircled by russian
troops joe biden is headed for a long
weekend in delaware that's just great
joe biden is now feeling fleeing the
white house taking off uh he needs his
rest and relaxation my guess is by now
he's probably had his ice cream and has
taken a long night's sleep it's been a
tough week for joe what an absolute
disgrace during this campaign biden once
proclaimed that a fifth year of donald
trump as president would spell a
disaster for ukraine as it turns out one
year under biden was far worse take a
look
to state the obvious and i'm ending here
promise you
we have to defeat donald trump
you know
[Music]
because we can't this is literal
we can't get a damn thing done
unless he's defeated it's going to take
a hell of a lot of work
to make up for all the damage he's done
internationally and nationally
his network of thugs and co-conspirators
are going to continue to try to
undermine our democracy in the meantime
imagine what he can do in another year
imagine what can happen in ukraine
well joe didn't want that that'd be bad
for the the family syndicate remember
zero experience hunter joe biden
leveraged one billion taxpayer dollars
he said you're not getting the billion
unless you fire this prosecutor named
shoken who's investigating his zero
experienced son hunter who's making
millions who admitted on abc that he had
no experience in energy oil gas or
ukraine why do you think they're paying
you millions then uh hunter i don't know
could it be because your dad's the vice
president in charge of ukrainian policy
that's that was the real quid pro quo
that the media mob ignored but back to
the issues of today by needs to turn
around get back to the white house or if
he can't do it and he's not up to the
job which i'm
every day americans are beginning to see
he's really not up to the job maybe it's
time to step aside let someone more
capable someone more cognitively alert
take the reins because this has the
potential to spiral out of control
really fast we're talking about an evil
maniacal
dictator with territorial ambitions that
probably go well beyond and even the
biden administration is admitting well
beyond ukraine and it's past time for
devastating sanctions on russian oil and
gas and if you're not willing to take
that one hard step
that means you're not willing to put the
pain on putin that he deserves because
without that pain what's going to stop
him from invading neighboring poland or
the baltic states okay well if an attack
on on one is an attack on all okay
that's the nato agreement
is that really going to work
if that happens will nato go to war with
russia
anyway it's either going to be world war
iii or we're going to abandon our allies
abandon nato nato will be exposed as a
paper tiger now don't forget what
happened in 1994 during the budapest
agreement that's when ukraine they
agreed to give up their nuclear arsenal
three years earlier in 1991 they seceded
from the former soviet union okay they
were the third largest holder of nuclear
weapons in the world and they were
holding on to those nuclear weapons as
part of this agreement in exchange
they handed those weapons back to russia
to be destroyed russia promised they'd
never attacked ukraine and that the u.s
and the uk would back them up meaning
the ukrainians what is the lesson from
this agreement i guess number one don't
ever give up nuclear weapons if you have
them number two under putin russia
doesn't give a flying rip about his word
agreements alliances nothing the only
thing that putin will respond to
is strength donald trump understood this
and by the way now europe and the u.s
they need to immediately take tough
action against russia's oil and gas
industry
that is where putin is getting off of
his money that is his greatest
vulnerability hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else